字幕: Harue Mori
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
あるところに
O（オー）という男がいました
Oは どもり持ちでした
ぷっ ぷ ぷぷぷぷぷ ぷるぷるぷるぷる
ぴっぴぴっぴぴぴぴぴぴ
ち ちぃぃちぃぃしぃぃしぃぃぃ
つつつつつつつつっつつつつつつつつ
んんん んんんん
喋る時に 言葉がつかえたり
喉の奥の方で詰まったり
そして時々 思うように
喋れないことがありました
こうして 毎日の会話に
なかなか苦労していたようです
電車乗り場で切符を買う時は
順番に並んでいるそばから
ソワソワしていました
「一ノ駅」「二ノ駅」「三ノ駅」とあって
Oは「二ノ駅」の切符が欲しかったのですが
「に」が言えなかったのです
「お客さんどちらまで？」
「んんああの・・・」
「はい？ どちらまで？」
「ん・・・さんのえきまで」
本当は「二ノ駅」なのに
その先の「三ノ駅」までを買いました
Oは その都度落ち込みました
「にのえき」が言えなかったからって？
いえ そうではありません
どもりを隠すために
本当は言いたくない
自分の気持ちに 嘘をついていたからです
こうして なかなか会話に
苦労していたようです
そんなOを 毎日
面白がってなのか心配してなのか
いろんな人が近づいてきました
「ッホエッホエッホエッホ
OさんOさん グッドモーニン
今日も一日バヴァグッデー
トットーカッカ」
東の山の方から 毎朝
ジョギングでやってくる ホッホ兄弟
「えぇえ Oさん ついに聞いてください
地中を流れる水の流れが
発見できそうです
こうして ダウジング棒を持っていくと
ほぉらここに 水が流れてます」
西の町で謎の井戸掘り研究をする
ウギ博士
「ふっふぅ〜！
今日も食パンが 焼けたわよぉ〜！
ツイストドーナツも いかがぁ〜？」
パン屋の売り子さんで
サンバを踊る クネクネ姉さん
ある時 町にいるいろんな人たちの
喋り方を見ていたOは
ふと その喋り方を真似してみました
すると
いつもよりスラスラと言葉が出てきたのです
「エッホエッホエッホエッホ
オオオオオーデス」
「Oさん おはよう！」
「ハジメマシテ オオオオオーデス」
「なんだよなんだよ 知ってるよ
びっくりしたなぁ」
「お客さん どちらまで？」
「えぇえ・・・
にのえき片道 大人1枚ください」
「ニャ〜オ」
「ヘイ キャッツ！
今日もネズミが獲れたか〜い？」
「ニャ〜オ・・・」
Oは 物真似がとっても得意でした
ところが 小さな細かい 癖の一つ一つまで
真似ができたものですから
いろんな人のいろんな特徴が
ぐちゃぐちゃに混ざって
ちぐはぐになってしまいました
Oは困りました
そこで もっとスラスラペラペラ
流暢な息遣いで
ズバっと切り込んで
ダダンと答えを出す人になろうと思いました
スラスラスラスラ
ペラペラペラペラペラ
りゅうちょうりゅうちょう
スバッ ダダン
スラスラスラスラスラスラ
ペラペラペラペラペラペラ
りゅうちょうりゅうちょう
スバッ ダダン
スラスラスラスラスラスラスラ
ペラペラペラペラペラペラ
りゅうちょうりゅうちょう
スバッ ダダン
繰り返し繰り返し
一心不乱に練習しました
すると
ある時 服の袖口あたりからなんだか
ぶら下がっていることに気がつきました
服の糸がほつれたのか
ゴミがくっついているのかよくわかりません
このまま引っ張ったら服に穴があいてしまうか
と一瞬頭によぎったのですが
えぇい面倒くさくなって
そのぶら下がっているものを
引きちぎりました
すると
それはわけもなく 床に落ちました
それでまた
スラスラスラスラスラスラペラペラペラペラ
りゅうちょうりゅうちょうスバダダ
スラスラスラスラペラペラペラペラ
りゅうちょうりゅうちょうスバッダダン
スラスラスラスラペラペラ
りゅうちょりゅうちょスバダダ・・・
あくる日も あくる日も
それはもう自分まるごと粘土で形作るみたいに
これでもかこれでもかと 練習しました
するとまた 身体のどこからか
なんだかぶら下がって
気になって というより
いつになく憎たらしく思えて
力いっぱい 引きちぎりました
それでまた
スラスラスラスラペラペラペラペラ
ついには 息の吸い方から
まばたきの仕方まで気になり始め
呪文のように唱えました
スラスラスラスラスラペラペラペラペラペラ
りゅうちょりゅうちょズバダダ
スラスラスラスラペラペラペラペラ・・・
Oは どんどん変わりました
喋るスピードは スポーツカーのように速く
頭の中で 完璧に整理した言葉を
順番通りに喋れるように
「無駄なことは一つも言わないやつだ」
と言われるようになり
立ち姿は自信にみなぎり
高級ブティックのスーツを着て
お金持ちの社長さんや
宝石まみれのおばさまと
大笑いしました
「はっはっはっはっはっ・・・」
そしていつしか独りになると
暗い部屋で じっとしていました
「おい！ Oさん最近
顔つき変わったんじゃねぇか？」
「あぁ 息もしないで
毎日出かけていくよ」
「家に帰っても 部屋の明かりもつけないで
どうしたのかしら？」
Oは いつもピリピリとして
目の下にクマを作って
こわばった目つきで
ついに周りの人も
声をかけなくなりました
やがて
Oの噂も 聞かなくなりました
ある日の夕暮れ時
車を運転していたOは
いつになく疲れを感じ
ゼーゼーと息が漏れました
だんだんと 眠気が押し寄せてきて
目の前の景色が
遠くになっていくのが見えた
次の瞬間！ 危ない！！
目の前に もくもくと
煙が立ち上っていました
すると
煙はだんだんと黒くなって
黒い煙がしゅうっと集まったかと思うと
大きな影になって
Oの目の前に覆い被さってきました
Oは朦朧としながら
その黒い影を見上げると
「おい・・・生きてるか？」
「誰だ！」
「誰だって・・・ オレは影だ」
「か・・・ 影？ だ・・・ 誰の？」
「誰のものでもない影だ
世の中に 持ち主のいない影
ってのも あるんだよ
あんた オレと取引しないか？」
「と・・・ 取引？」
「そう難しく考えることはねぇんだよ
おぅ あんた 自分の影 見てみな」
［驚く］
「色が薄くなってんだろう？
消えかかってる」
「ど・・・ どういうことだよ？」
「慌てるな
あんたなぁ
自分の影を捨てちまったんだよ
あんた どもりがあったなぁ
喋るときにつっかえたり繰り返したり
それはあんたの中にいたな
いろんな自分がやっていたことで
あんたの中には これまで
前のめりでつんのめっているようなやつや
のんびりゆったりしてるやつや
顔だけ巣穴から出してる狸みたいに
キョロキョロしてるようなやつまで
そいつらは あんたがこれまでの人生で
出会ってきたものたちさ
そいつらがあんたの中で
折り重なって折り重なって
あんた これまでやってきた
ところが
どもりに苦しんだあんたは
スラスラとふん詰まらずに
必死になって必死になるほど
その のんびりのやつや
つんのめりが
邪魔になって切り離しちまった
切り離されたそいつらは
行き場がなくなって
ただの影だけになった
一度切り離された影は
二度と戻らねぇよ
このままだとあんた
消えてしまう
そこで 取引だ
オレを あんたの影にしないか？」
「すると・・・ どうなるんだよ？」
「消えずに済むよ
その代わり あんたの半分がオレになる」
「・・・半分？
いや・・・ だめ・・・」
「はっはっはっは
わかったわかった
まぁそうくると思ったよ
それじゃあ こうしよう
あんたが消えずに済む方法を
教えてやる」
「頼む！」
「その代わり
オレは あんたの言葉が欲しい
あんたの喋り方は
人を自分の世界に巻き込む力がある
そんなふうにスラスラっと喋られたら
大抵の人間はコロっといっちまう
そうだろう？
オレは あんたの話術が欲しいんだよ」
「もし オレの言葉を渡したら
どうなんだよ？
またどもりに戻るのか？
どうなんだよ？」
「ちゃんと考えてあるさ
落ち着いて聞いてくれ
あんたの中にな
最後の一つだけ残ってる影がある
それがあんたにとって最後のチャンスだ」
「オレの中に 一つ・・・？」
「そうだよ
もしあんたが
自分の言葉を渡すんだったら
その影とうまくやっていく方法を教えてやる
そうすりゃあんたの存在も
消えることはねぇよ」
「わかった やってくれ」
「よし！ 取引成立だ！ いいか？
あんたの中に残ってる最後の影はなぁ
“タナム”という子どもの影だ
タナムは 耳が聞こえない
あんたが子どもの頃に会った子だ
タナムは 目の前で
口を大きく開いて喋れば
口の形で何を言っているのかがわかった
そうやって聞こえなくても
会話することができて
あんたは嬉しかった
その嬉しい気持ちがあんたの中に
ずっと棲み続けてたのさ
それこそ
他の影を切り離しちまった時も
その音に気づかず
ずっとあんたの中に
残ってたってわけさ
あんたは
タナムと会った時のことを思い出しゃ
その影とうまくやっていくことができるさ
あんたは言葉を失う
もう どもりですらなくなる
その代わり
まったく別の 音のない言葉の世界で
ゼロから生きていくんだよ
心の準備はいいか？
今から
三つ数えるうちに
オレはあんたの
言葉をいただいていなくなる
一つ
二つ
みっ・・・」
その後のことは 誰も知りません
そしてある時
Oに 一つの言葉が生まれました
ありがとうございました
（拍手）